l'hiver nous expliquait il ya quelques
instants que les soldats russes sont
entrés à kharkiv deuxième ville
d'ukraine c'est un conseiller du
ministère vous craignez de l'intérieur
qui a fait l'annoncé ce qu'on comprend
c'est que globalement les ukrainiens
résiste à commencer par le symbole parmi
les symboles à savoir kiev la capitale
oui il ya une vraie mobilisation une
vraie résistance un des ukrainiens on le
voit dans dans tous les reportages et
c'est vrai que ce peuple ukrainien il
est un peu galvanisait aussi par la
manière dont se comportent leur
président leur jeune président volodymyr
zelensky qui a une politique de
communication très affûté sur les
réseaux sociaux et donc ils se sentent
un peu galvanisé et pour le moment du
coup ça ralentit la progression des
forces russes sur la progression
justement de sa force russe qu'est ce
qu'on peut dire à l'heure qu'il est de
leur évolution sur le terrain eh bien
écoutez si on regarde donc la carte
l'inquiéter voilà à l'écran à l'instant
on voit que c'est toujours un peu la
même stratégie c'est à dire qu'il ya une
offensive vers le nord pour aller vers
kiev un peu plus à l'est vers le
nord-est pour aller sur karkhiv et c'est
important car qui fait effectivement
c'est la deuxième ville du pays et c'est
là que les russes ce matin visiblement
ont commencé à entrer dans la ville et
puis évidemment offensive par l'est à
partir du donbass et par le sud à partir
de la crimée et là ce matin il ya deux
villes gulliver l'évoquer il ya quelques
minutes personne et berné ernst qui sont
littéralement encerclé donc là aussi il
faudra surveiller voir ce qui se passe
dans les prochaines heures personne
c'est très important parce que c'est à
l'entrée du fleuve dniepr qui ensuite
remonte jusqu à kiev donc c'est pas la
première fois dans l'histoire de
l'ukraine que des armes et qui
envahissent ou qui tentent d'envahir le
pays en fait chercherait à s'emparer de
ce verrou stratégique c'est très
important à personne parce que c'est
vraiment
alors à l'embouchure de la mer noire le
début du fleuve dniepr qui ensuite
remonte comme ça jusqu à kiev souvent
les armées qui envahissent et bien
remonte ce fleuve qui en plus marque une
une sorte de séparation si vous voulez
entre l'est et l'ouest de l'ukraine